when we asked who you wanted to see on
sound field
this is what you said
in the world of avant-garde music
historians mostly talk about white men's
contributions to the genre
often times overlooking the presence and
musical offerings of the lgbtq
black and poc artists we want to explore
noise music
its origins and the underrepresented
artists who create noise in experimental
music
one of those artists is the rising
underground musician dream crusher
i should make this very clear i mainly
call myself a noise musician
because white people hate when i do that
my music's a bunch of different stuff
you could like classify it as noise um
but i'm really not into the whole genre
purism thing
i think it's really wack my usual
co-host naray soul is off working on her
album
so i asked musician and vocalist linda
diaz to meet up with dream crusher in
new york city
who comes to your shows and if it is a
lot of like black queer
people and or artists how does that
influence them or do you how do you feel
like
that impacts them at your shows
historically
with punk shows or noise shows or
whatever
so many queer people and just young
people in plc
like don't feel comfortable
[Music]
[Applause]
like a lot of queer kids come to my
shows now
it is nice to like say that you're a
thing and
people who are also that thing feel a
firm bite and show up and show their
face to you
and yeah tell you how your work affected
them that's like
it's amazing and it like it gives more
meaning to the work
which is cool
so what is noise music noise is hard to
define and most people agree that it's
subjective
as music theorist torben sangiel put it
what is noise to one person can be
meaningful to another
what was considered an unpleasant sound
yesterday is not today
the term noise dates back to 1913 when
futurist artist and musician luigi
rosolo published his groundbreaking
manifesto the art of noises
rosolo said that the industrial
revolution created an entirely new
landscape of sounds to explore
the noises of metal screeching and the
construction of skyscrapers gave
listeners a greater capacity to
experience new sounds
another influence on composers of the
era was world wars 1 and 2.
life was a lot bleaker back then which
led a lot of musicians and composers to
experiment
and move away from melodic music since
then the genre has been shaped by art
movements such as data and surrealism
one of the greatest influences in noise
has been the fluxus movement
these artists emphasize the artistic
process over the finished product
listen to ben patterson's paper piece
which was created by giving five
performers pieces of paper and
directions on how to crumple
scrub and twist them
ben patterson a black artist born in
1934 was one of the co-founders of the
fluxus movement but his contributions
are often overlooked for his peers like
yoko ono and john cage
this gets us back to dream pressure
performing at st fighters bar in
brooklyn new york
what does your music sound like or how
do you make a song
there was this kid that like had never
gone to a show of mine before that like
walked up to me it was probably in
philly i feel like kids are a lot a lot
more vocal in philly
but he walks up to me and he goes that
sounded like a plane crashing
for like half an hour
i make all my music mainly on a computer
um more recently i've been using a lot
more samples
yeah i make like 90 of my own sound
effects and stuff like that i just
downloaded a program and
started like i didn't really i still
honestly i still don't know what i'm
doing
i just like mess with stuff and then
like hopefully it comes out right
what program did you start on like was
it like a garage band situation was it
like a phone
voice note type thing i still do most of
my vocals on my phone
um i use i still use fl studio um
for literally the first 12 years that i
made anything it was the trial version
and
i couldn't i couldn't save anything and
then if i like didn't like how it came
out
i would like just do it again
dream crusher's ability to record
distribute and design their own handmade
tapes and albums
perform hundreds of shows and create
heavily nuanced soundscapes with
socially and politically charged lyrics
has made them a staple in the world of
post-modern noise music
i mean put it like this like one of the
times i saw
we we played together and the lucid saw
you
was just like oh it sounds like a world
like a planet is being born
and i was like yeah yes that's what he
said
yeah but essentially yeah you were a
world builder and
also just like a sweet
like like projecting of love type of
person you know i mean like there was a
genuine sort of sense in your spirit and
whatnot so
like when you first moved to new york
how many shows were you playing
oh yeah oh yeah i've i've played like i
think 108 shows
in 2015 when i first moved here what
i didn't have a place to live and
whoever i was playing with i would just
like hey
anybody got a couch and i was like
sleeping at penn station for a little
bit
it was like that was a mess but like i
made it to shows on time
did sound check and everything like hey
do a lot of people
think of you as like the first to do
what you're doing
like the i think a lot of people
think that or it's the first time
they've seen somebody like me make it
and that's alive
although dream pressure exerts their
strong beliefs on individualism and
their music and art
they also consider themselves to be a
part of a community of black
poc and queer noise musicians they told
the fader
i always ask people to research the
history of people of color in noise and
queer people in noise
people aren't paying attention to that
so my main mission is that i want people
to stop treating me like i'm an anomaly
because i'm not one of dream crusher's
musical influences
is the renowned japanese noise artist
bruno's bow
since the 70s and 1980s japan has been a
leading creator of noise music
so much so that the music scene inspired
its own sub genre called japan noise
music journalist cleary mallard writes
noise takes it further than any other
genre
rhythm melody lyrics standard
instruments
all forgotten across the world people
experiment with this style but japan
noise was one of the greatest catalysts
for its existence today
bands like hijo kaidon and melt banana
thrashed into the north american music
lexicon
creating a globalized alternative and
more importantly
a level of equality with white noise
bands like sonic youth and psychic tv
dream pressure was even featured on a
compilation curated by adult swim
entitled noise alongside the music of
mers bow and melt banana
but wait the connection wins even deeper
masami akita of mersbow and dreamcrusher
are both influenced by free jazz and the
other worldly music experimentalists
[Music]
sunrock
free jazz is a form of tonal
experimentation which approaches jazz
improvisation
in unconventional ways such as
deconstructing chords and tempos to
create discordant compositions in the
1950s and 1960s
artists like albert aylor cecil taylor
and poet and musician
amiri varaka all rejected traditional
jazz composition to map new territory
and open doors for experimental black
artists to rebel against resident
syncopated politically neutral music
instead these artists spoke their minds
about the times they were living in
the rise of modern recording and sound
processing techniques
specifically distortion also influenced
the development
of electronic and noise music an example
of this is the practice music conflict
where the composer edits and distorts
recorded sounds to make a piece of music
listen to wings of the delirious demon
by ilhan mimadolu
composed by manipulating the pitch of a
clarinet recording
the invention of the mooc synthesizer in
1964 was a breakthrough for experimental
musicians
these instruments are the precursors to
a lot of computer generated sounds heard
in experimental and noise music
the instrument was brought into the
mainstream by transgender artist wendy
carlos
and her album switched on the bach in
1968.
she later went on to produce synthesized
soundtracks for stanley kubrick's
clockwork orange and the shining
uh so how were you inspired by wendy
carlos my mom's a big cinephile
and um one of the first like movies
from like her era was a clockwork orange
it's so sick to see like something like
that because
so um i don't know i just almost every
other image of music i ever saw was like
people playing real instruments
new york's downtown music scene was also
an influence on the formation of noise
music
set off by yoko ono in 1960 when she
opened her downtown loft for
unconventional music performances
the live music downtown differed from
the more traditional classical music
played uptown by the lincoln center
one of the musicians of new york's
downtown scene was minimalist composer
julius eastman
a lot of his avant-garde compositions
focused on his identity as a black queer
[Music]
man
why do your fans love you so much why do
they love your music
i hope it's because um they
escape through my work i hope that it's
because
um i provide something very unique
musically
for them
i don't see a lot of black non-binary
people
like being in pitchfork in stereo gum
like on npr on or pbs
[Laughter]
but like i hope that like people seeing
me
will like open the not open the
floodgates necessarily because
ain't they ain't that many of us but
there's enough of us to like
like come on like you feel like it is a
political act
the art that you make or you as an
artist i'm just making things that make
me happy
yeah if that's what it takes to affirm
other black queer artists or people of
color who
want to make something that they didn't
grow up around or like
get any affirmation from and it's like
all right like i want to like be able to
make space for them too
[Music]
soundfield finally has a patreon where
you can support us get behind the scenes
concert footage
and early access to every new episode
link in the description
one last thing before i go we do a
survey every year that helps us make
more of the stuff you want to see
you even get to vote on potential new
shows find the link below
and tell them sound field is your
favorite